[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie a tutti a tutti
Ho pensato Giorni interi a questo
discorso perché sentivo una
responsabilità perché davanti a me ci
siete voi che forse state cercando
risposte quando mi hanno invitata a
parlare di Balance equilibrio non mi
sono sentita all'altezza Forse perché è
un equilibrio ancora non ce l'ho perché
lo sto ancora cercando
in queste settimane questo pensiero mi
balenava costantemente nella testa e non
mi mollava un equilibrio non ce l'ho
mi veniva da ridere e mi vergognavo in
realtà sapevo cosa dovevo dirvi la
verità quando mi ritrovo a lavorare 10
ore al giorno e non ho nemmeno la forza
di cucinarmi un equilibrio non ce l'ha
Quando Vorrei mollare tutto e fare altro
quando ancora non so amare e farmi amare
quando mi guarda allo specchio ancora
non mi piaccio quando Vorrei scappare un
equilibrio non ce l'ho
Come avrei potuto io parlare di
equilibrio
sapevo in realtà cosa dovevo dirvi la
verità e la verità è che non sempre
avete risposte non sempre saprete Dove
state andando e tante volte vi sentirete
soli non sono qui oggi a raccontare una
storia di successo di un equilibrio
trovato e mai lasciato perché questo non
è possibile
dominarsi mantenere la calma rimanere
padroni di sé quante volte questo non è
successo
È normale e va bene così pensiamo spesso
che i percorsi che facciamo abbiano la
loro fine
dobbiamo perseguire per raggiungere i
nostri obiettivi cerchiamo
definizioni categorie cerchiamo di
spiegarci e spesso non ce la facciamo
immaginiamo la vita piuttosto come un
cerchio in cui andiamo avanti e torniamo
indietro in cui ci perdiamo in cui ci
ritroviamo e ruotiamo intorno a noi come
fanno le stelle e la terra
la vita è piuttosto un cerchio e
l'equilibrio è un eterno palleggiamento
fra movimento e stabilità
Oggi siamo schiacciati da storie di
successo di chi ce l'ha fatta io sono
qui per raccontarvi l'opposto per
parlare a chi non ce la fa per dirvi che
è normale non sentirsi all'altezza
Oggi sono qui per vedermi umana e per SP
per spronare voi stessi a fare lo stesso
con voi e con gli altri perché sarete
più leggeri più liberi e sarà tutto più
vero più semplice più felice
Forse ogni tanto possiamo arrenderci a
queste non risposte a non sapere cosa
fare o al nulla
possiamo affidarci a quello che verrà e
che sarà Abbassando la pressione e la
responsabilità che sentiamo su di noi si
apre davanti a noi un orizzonte di
possibilità in cui respiriamo leggeri
non abbiate paura di non avere risposte
di deporre le armi di non sapere chi
siete di avere paura oggi sono qui per
parlare di ciò che è normale terreno
Reale al di fuori di quello che ci fanno
credere Oggi sono qui per essere onesta
avevo 13 anni quando ho scelto di essere
una psicologa perché stavo male e volevo
capire perché ma soprattutto Volevo dire
a quella persona davanti a me non sei
sola
soprattutto volevo stare vicino agli
altri e dargli comprensione ascolto
quello che io non mi ero data quello che
io non avevo avuto quando lavoro con i
miei pazienti le loro splendide
fragilità vengono fuori le loro storie
la loro solitudine
mi sono fatta le spalle grosse ma ancora
oggi quando torna a casa mi faccio
piccola piccola e cerco una coperta che
mi copra tutta
da quando sono nata mi sono sentita
strana diversa inadeguata per una
società che ti vuole in un certo modo
quando sei un bambino ti devi divertire
quando sei alle medie devi avere una
vita sociale
quando sei al liceo devi essere Cool
quando sei all'università devi essere
bravo quando lavori devi essere
performante il venerdì e il sabato devi
uscire devi bere
e così via tutto questo non fa che
costruire le nostre prigioni
non Cadete nei tranelli della società e
disattendete quello che ci si aspetta da
voi nella vita mantenere il proprio
equilibrio è difficile
vi metteranno sotto pressione vi
allontaneranno dalla vostra verità Non
c'è colpa e Fa parte del gioco
la complessità di quello che abbiamo
davanti non si può mai ridurre a degli
standard da raggiungere io ancora oggi
non so chi sono Eppure a voi potrebbe
sembrare che di cose ne ho fatte Laura
dedilektis psicologa clinica creatrice
di donne per strada
amministratrice delegata di Viola volcom
tutto questo non significa niente e non
parla di me non sono i risultati che
raggiungete che vi definiscono ma quello
che c'è dietro l'amore che ci mettete
voi stessi noi non soffriamo per quello
che siamo noi soffriamo per quello che
non siamo e per quello che pensiamo che
dovremmo essere
quando non ci sentiamo amati per quello
che siamo pensiamo di non meritare
l'amore e pensiamo di dovercelo
conquistare di dover cambiare noi stessi
diventando quello che gli altri
vorrebbero che fossimo Oppure quello che
pensiamo che gli altri vorrebbero che
fossero così via
Non c'è colpa Siamo tutti vittime della
stessa mancanza
ho provato tante volte a cambiare me
stessa e per fortuna non ce l'ho fatta
perché quello che siamo ritorna sempre
perché quello che siamo si fa necessario
e urgente quando tradiamo noi stessi
Questa è l'unica cosa da fare per
trovare un equilibrio che non sia
costante ma che sia vero che sia il
vostro che parli di voi di come vedete
il mondo per ognuno diverso il vostro
modo di esprimervi e di essere non
tradite voi stessi e se lo fate non vi
sentite in colpa Ma tornate a casa
accogliendovi e ricominciando
rispettate voi stessi con il rischio di
deludere gli altri con il rischio di non
piacere con il rischio di fare male
all'inizio vi sentirete in colpa
Ma poi capirete che era l'unica opzione
possibile per continuare a vivere
e anche chi ama chi vi ama lo capirà
tendete sempre la verità non vi fermate
in questa ricerca mettete in discussione
tutto perdendovi completamente
lascerete andare quello che non siete o
quello che non siete più è quello che
non siate mai stati
e si pulirà il cielo della vostra vita
Respirate ridete ballate
disperatevi implorate
sbagliate
accettatevi per quello che siete nelle
vostre complessità nelle vostre
incoerenti incoerenze nel vostro essere
unici e normali allo stesso tempo
Amatevi in tutto quello che siete senza
dover nascondere nemmeno un briciolo di
voi stessi
andando fuori e a testa alta amandovi
come nessuno vi ha mai amato prima
dandovi quello che ancora non avete
avuto e che meritate
abbassate le armi chiedete aiuto siate
umane Allora planete dall'alto sulle
vostre vite e la paura non vi farà più
paura perché la conoscerete e i giorni
di tempesta e giorni di sole Li
affronterete allo stesso modo
la più grande forza è sentire la propria
fragilità le proprie paure per
arrendersi a qualcosa di più semplice e
onesto noi stessi
lasciate entrare nella vostra vita le
persone non abbiate paura non ci si può
mai proteggere abbastanza E se si pensa
solo a proteggersi si perde tutto
l'amore
Fatevi amare come potete e amate come
riuscite come siete Non c'è cosa più
bella di avere persone accanto la paura
di non essere amati non ci fa vedere
l'amore che già abbiamo intorno
fidatevi e affidatevi all'inizio questo
discorso lo stavo scrivendo da sola poi
tante persone ci sono entrate dentro
e ho sentito questa come la cosa più
bella che esiste non essere soli non
siamo soli anche se lo pensiamo anche se
siamo disperati
condividiamo quello che siamo in
qualunque forma ci sarà sempre qualcuno
che ci ama per quello che siamo
in questi giorni ero pronta da da ad
andarmene ma sono rimasta
l'inferno dei viventi non è qualcosa che
sarà se ce n'è uno è quello che ha già
qui l'inferno che abitiamo tutti i
giorni che Formiamo Stando insieme
due modi ci sono per non soffrirne il
primo riesce facile a molti
accettare l'Inferno e diventarne parte
fino al punto di arrivare a non vederlo
più
il secondo rischioso ed esige
un'attenzione un apprendimento continui
trovare in mezzo all'inferno chi e che
cosa non lo è e dargli spazio e farlo
durare Italo Calvino Grazie